[Music]
what is the oven Adi policy issue that
you've been talking about over the years
the truth the truth the truth that is my
policy that is my policy issue quote
unquote
well the downside of being a cable news
host is you can't even step away for a
few days without the creepy porn lawyer
hatching a new plot to get himself back
on television mark Stein was in this
chair to cover it all when it happened
so I was abroad fishing defending my
country as I always do when I'm outside
its borders and then I come back to find
it CPL the creepy porn lawyer he's
thinking about running for president and
I'm kind of crestfallen I'm not really
sure what to make of this how did you
cover it when you were sitting he
announced his campaign at the Iowa State
Fair which is where one goes apparently
to find a creepy porn lawyer it's it's
like between the 4-h barn and the
petting zoo the creepy porn lawyer has
his stand there and he's selling bloomin
onions and all the rest of it and he's
announced that he is a shoo-in for the
Democrat nomination in 2020 and in fact
in my state of New Hampshire he's
planning on coming here in the next
couple of weeks and stumping New
Hampshire by the way stumping New
Hampshire was one of my favorite stormy
Daniels movies sit there and passively
accept this I mean I've argued a few
years than your state ought to have
built a southern border wall to keep
Massachusetts at you ignored me and look
what happened but you're gonna sit
having not learned that lesson and let's
EPL invade your state without any
response at all is that what you're
saying well I'm not you know that as I
said the creepy porn lawyer is is at
state fairs that's your problem with
America right there that's where it's
all that's the death of the Republic is
you can't even go to the county fair and
not a demean it's inevitable in a way
America employees as many lawyers as the
rest of the planet combined so it makes
the certain sense that they're actually
a County Fair now and you know I'd
rather just have something wholesome
like a greased pig race but if we can't
of that then having a creepy porn lawyer
race at the Lancaster fair in new
picture which is coming up in a couple
of weeks
that's as yes as we can get if your eyes
are that close together do you have
peripheral vision or is this really a
question for an ophthalmologist I guess
yeah we'll get a doctor's opinion on
that funnel cake and the creepy porn
lawyer come to New Hampshire that is in
the end probably not going anywhere I
want to get your very quick prediction
on this mark could we we're mocking it
now but could this become real well a
lot of things we mock if you remember do
become real and president president porn
lawyer could well be in the cards
you are welcome on this show anytime
today I'm not Bill Kristol I'm not going
never porn lawyer right off out of the
game you never know what could happen
you're a wise man Mark Steyn great to
see you thanks for sitting in by the way
you were great oh they would say the
guest host at the end of last week you
should have got Michael avenatti he'd
have done a much better job no I don't
know who that is that's about it for us
tonight every night at 8:00 this showed
that the sworn enemy of lying papacy
smugness and groupthink Sean Hannity
right now